you're single and you're a very fun you
are attractive fellow I'll say that for
you thank you do you you have a special
technique for meeting women that could
be a little difficult in LA isn't
actually meeting them what do you do
have a unique way of meeting women this
is what I do when I'm in a grocery store
right I look into a woman shopping cart
see what she has think about what she
might need then post up in hile and wait
on her to come get it I see like I walk
by the car and I look in there and I say
she got hot dogs hot dog buns that [ __ ]
gonna need relish and then I go look for
the road and then when she gets to the
relish you're just leaning when I'm lean
against the relish like this you every
if you get into a bad date I'm told you
have kind of a unique way of getting out
of a bad date that tastes not going down
well you're able to get out of it what's
your tech what I do is I like to take
pictures of car accidents and people
fighting on the street and cars Tigers
being blown I'll take pictures of those
and I use them from my lies later on
like if I'm on a date with somebody I'm
like hold to you she go 19 I go my boy
just caught caught in a fire in his car
and I gotta send me a picture yeah he
took a picture of himself on fire makes
no sense I don't know why works though
yeah she always don't you want me to go
with you no they have a water hose where
[Laughter]
you